[Applaus]
[Musik]
es war einmal Leben einem baufälligen
Militärflughafen vor der
Altersversicherung Schrauber und
Kampfflugzeuge kleinen Stadt namens San
Antonio de los Banos meine Stadt
kolonialen Ursprungs welche im ganzen
Land als die Hauptstadt des Humors
bekannt war und immerhin ist er der
Veranstaltungsorte internationalen gehen
alle des grafischen Humors doch ab Juli
2021 könnte sie besser bekannt werden
als das kubanische Epizentrum für
schlechte Stimmung und soziale
Unzufriedenheit an Gründen mangelt es
wahrlich nicht Kuba steht vor der
schlimmsten Lebensmittelknappheit seit
den 1990 er Jahren
Kuba erkennt Mangel an Medikamenten an
der Ort an dem alles ist die Menschen
die
Menschen
[Musik]
diese Prozesse Namen ihren Ursprung also
außerhalb Havanna breiten sich jedoch
schnell im ganzen Lande aus vor allem in
den Provinzen Maja wecke und Matanzas wo
sich z.b. die Touristenhochburg Varadero
befindet auch in der Hauptstadt in
Havanna selbst gab es dann zahlreiche
Protestkundgebungen dieses Mal waren die
Proteste etwas seltsam nicht nur weil es
in einer kommunistischen Diktatur die
Kuhbar selten vorkommt dass es überhaupt
Proteste gibt sondern auch weil es das
erste Mal ist das eine groß angelegte
Protestwelle zumindest für kubanische
Verhältnisse außerhalb der Hauptstadt
begonnen hat
[Musik]
denn im Gegensatz zu anderen
lateinamerikanischen Ländern hat ist das
coolste verschieden das Gruber seit mehr
als 60 Jahren regiert geschafft eine
starken Illusionen Rahmen zu schaffen
der jeden Winkel des Landes erreicht die
Skizze Diktatur eine Position der
breiten Herrschaft und Kontrolle über
die gesamte Bevölkerung in der Tat ist
das kubanische régine eines der wenigen
politischen Regimes ist trotz aller
Schwierigkeiten geschafft haben den Fall
der Berliner Mauer und Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion zu überleben darüber hinaus
überlegt dass erschienen sogar die große
Wirtschaftskrise die das Land zwischen
1990 und 94 heimsuchte welche die
Stränge Rationierung grundlegende
Alltags gute und schwere Materie
Engpässe verursachte die bis heute
anhalten es war eine Zeit in der Kuba in
nur drei Jahren 63 % seines
Bruttoinlandsprodukt verloren Einschlag
von der sich das Land erst nach mehr als
17 Jahren erholen würde denn die
Sowjetunion war viel viel mehr als nur
ein politischer Verbündeter für Kuba
gewesen sie war jahrzehntelang der
eigentliche wirtschaftliche Motor der
Insel
Beispiel zu Forschungsreisen Albaöl dass
die Kubaner dann zum Teil exportierten
um sich Dollar zu beschaffen Kuba
erhielt auch zinsgünstige Kredite aus
Moskau das heißt sehr langfristige
Kredite mit sehr niedrigen Zinssätzen
und einfacher Rückzahlung die Kubaner
wurden auch für die Anwesenheit von
Truppen der Roten Armee auf der Insel
entschädigt und exportierten den
Großteil ihrer Produktion in der
sowjetischen macht um die eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben etwa 70% des
gesamten kubanischen Handels wurde in
die Union der Sozialistischen
Sowjetrepubliken geleitet von der UdSSR
abhängig von Spanien und den Vereinigten
Staaten in der gesamten Geschichte
gewesen war
die UdSSR
[Musik]
Anfang August 994 hielten die
kubanischen Behörden für Boote mit
Flüchtlingen fest die auf dem Weg in die
Vereinigten Staaten waren um in der
Krise zu entkommen das war der Tropfen
der das Fass zum Überlaufen brachte
hunderte und aberhunderte von Menschen
versammelten sich auf Havanna Malecon an
der breiten Strandpromenade bewaffnet
mit Stöcken und Steinen
die stellen sich gegen die Polizei
installierten Parolen gegen den
damaligen Präsidenten und Diktator
fridell Castro wenn auch Blatt das
kultische Regime entgegen aller
Widerstände bis heute an der Macht denn
wie ich schon sagte neben Rainer
Repression haben sie ein anderes Mittel
gefunden dass ihnen die Macht sicher den
Institutionalismus den sie über das
ganze Land wie ein engmaschiges Netz
gekriegt haben das Land ist totalitär
aber ist nur zionel durch und durch
in der Tat ist die politische Situation
Alec und Funktion des kubanischen
Regimes größtenteils von der
sowjetischen Erfahrung inspiriert es
unterhält sehr ausgefeilte
Machtstrukturen auf Regierungs und
Militär Ebene das heißt es gibt so gut
wie keine Verräter oder bedeutende
interne Machtkämpfe außerdem verfügt die
Regierung über eine der besten
Sicherheits und Nachrichtendienste
Lateinamerikas genau das ist der Grund
warum trotz aller Krisen die Insel
erlitten hat der Traum von Freiheit und
Demokratie für das kubanische Volk immer
sehr sehr weit entfernt und schwer zu
erreichen war aber ich wette dass ich an
diesem Punkt alles fragen wie um alles
in der Welt ist es dann zu den Bildern
gekommen die Kuba Karte gesehen haben
was hat eine solche sozial Explosion
ausgelöst welche Ursachen Umstände
stecken dahinter und vielleicht die
wichtigste Frage von allen werden die
Proteste weitergehen und es diesmal
schaffen das Regime zu stürzen diesem
Video werde euch alles genau erklären
also aufgepasst
[Musik]
unaufhaltsame Welle der Freiheit
das Kuba ist Jahres 2020 ist nicht mehr
das Gruber des Jahres 2015 nicht einmal
das Gruber des Jahres 2020 das Land hat
bedeutende Veränderung erlebt die bis
vor wenigen Jahren schlichtweg undenkbar
gewesen wären Veränderung die sich zwar
wieder in der Regierung noch in der
Verbesserung der Wirtschaft oder
politischen Freiheit niedergeschlagen
haben aber in einer gewissen Weise
verwandelt haben z.b. die meisten der
jüngeren Generation
ist die USA nicht mehr als eines
Tages werden können
Änderung nicht gefunden haben gibt es
eine Sache die einen echten Wendepunkt
darstellte des mobilen Internet
Faktoren der die Menschen bei den
Protesten im Juli 2020 am meisten
mobilisiert hatten jetzt im Dienst auf
der kurzen nicht gab
2018 mobile Internet Dezember durch das
Internet zugreifen
[Musik]
denn obwohl das Internet in Kuba strengt
sind wird es in Kuba mit Hilfe von VPN
also verschlüsselt Netzwerken Cologne
ein Fenster zu öffnen unter anderem
können Sie direkt ohne Filter und mit
ihren Familien und Freunden in Spanien
oder unterhalten das ist klar das beste
Gegenmittel gegen politische Propaganda
natürlich geht es aber nicht nur um
private Kommunikation
[Musik]
als Raul Castro begannen die Zügel an
den neuen politischen Führer der Insel
Präsident Miguel diaz-canel zu übergeben
waren die Erwartungen groß würde dies
endlich jeder Führer sein der Offenheit
und Wandel in Kuba fördern würde nun
theoretisch Straße diaz-canel für
wichtigere Formel 1 die Öffnung Kubatur
Welt die Zulassung von Privatdetektiven
Unselbständigkeit oder direkter
ausländische Investitionen im Grunde ein
Kurswechsel den viele kommunistische
Diktaturen im Laufe der Jahre
erfolgreich durchlaufen haben um
Wohlstand zu ermöglichen und ja es ist
wahr dass einige Veränderung
stattgefunden haben angefangen mit dem
Internetzugang aber in anderen Bereichen
die ist quälend langsam zu langsam voran
die wirtschaftliche Situation
verbesserte sich kaum die Erwartungen
der Menschen wurden alles andere als
erfüllt
eigentlich ist das alles relativ einfach
zu erklären was die Bahn im Jahr 2021
wollen vor allem die jungen ist sehr
simpel sie wollen die neuesten Handy
Modelle die Akkus in den Händen halten
können die Autos die fahren sie würden
gerne über alles was ich wollen reden
können ohne Angst vor zahlen oder
einfach nur frei reisen sie wollten das
einfach eine Zukunftsperspektive und ein
normales Leben Freiheit und genau diese
Tatsache hat den Boden bereitet das
Leben einfach nicht funktioniert einfach
nicht das Richtige ist
Evolution die sie unterstützt haben
erschwerend kommt hinzu eine Generation
die am meisten protestiert hat einer
Generation ist die während der Periode
geboren wurde der schweren
Wirtschaftskrise die bereits gesehen
haben auf den Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion folgte kurz gesagt handelt
es sich um eine Generation die etwas
anderes als Krise
nicht zu verlieren aber viel zu gewinnen
und genau das verraten wir euch jetzt
[Musik]
der letzte Strohhalm
um jene Gründe zu verstehen
[Musik]
Hotel der Insel gehören wir sprechen
hier von mir als 83 Hotelanlagen mit
21000 Zimmern und ein Umsatz unter
normalen Dingen von mehr als 700
Millionen US-Dollar nun schon 2019 die
Touristenzahlen Kuba deutlich
zurückgenommen so war das Ergebnis 2020
einfach katastrophal der internationalen
die auf die Insel kam praktisch und die
kubanische Regierung verläuft drei
Milliarden US-Dollar Einnahmen und
obwohl ich die Dinge 2021 verbessert
haben kubanische
der Vorjahre zurück also in einer
solchen Situation natürlich jede
erdenkliche Einkommensquelle
und genau aus diesem Grund entschied
sich die diaz-canel Regierung in Bezug
auf die Pandemie einfach mal weg zu
schauen und die Ankunft von
international Brüsten fast ohne
Einschränkungen zu fördern die toasten
kam vor allem aus ihrem Land aus dem in
den letzten Jahren das größte Wachstum
Besucherzahlen nach Kuba vermeldet
werden konnte wird in Russland Problem
gerade einen heftigen Coronavirus durch
die Delta Variante mehr als 150
russische Touristen sind in Kuba in
Quarantäne nachdem sie positiv auf
covid-19 getestet worden und beachte das
war
hauptsächlich
betroffen
[Musik]
MPREIS beeindruckte Tourismuszahlen 2020
wo dachte lange Warteschlangen vor den
Lebensmittelgeschäften der Grund den
Großteil der Lebensmittel
importieren das Land kommt 20% seines
eigenen Bedarf decken wir sprechen von
etwa 1,8 Milliarde
Lebensmittelimporte aufbringen muss die
Einkäufe werden natürlich auf dem
internationalen Markt getätigt und
müssen in Dollar oder Euro bezahlt
werden und
was ist Kuba Dollars und Euros
2020 Touristen kamen wurde das Regime
sehr kompliziert da jede dazu kommen die
ist nun mal braucht um Lebensmittel zu
blockieren die Untertanen nicht einfach
so verhungern und Devisenbeschaffung in
Krisen ist vor allem ganz kompliziert
wenn du ein niemand vertraut und dir
niemand etwas leihen will auf diese
Weise entstanden schwere Engpässe bei
fast allem und ein Teufelskreis Kalender
an
sehr stark eingeschränkt und sehr
unproduktive Wirtschaftssystem von
Staatsbetrieben das völlig
dysfunktionale ist und unter
Marktbedingungen nicht wettbewerbsfähig
ist extreme Kontrolle über alles was auf
der Esel kommt Kurth gesagt das perfekte
Rezept für eine Katastrophe die
vielleicht grösste Fehlkalkulation der
diaz-canel Regierung aber war dass sie
nie gedacht hätte dass die Situation so
außer Kontrolle geraten würde dass dies
die größten Proteste der Geschichte
Kubas auslösen würde Proteste den noch
größer sind als die des Marco Nase
Aufstandes von 1994 um die eine
Vorstellung zu gehen es wurden 40
Demonstration in einem einzigen Tag
gemeldet dass offensichtlich nicht die
übliche Zahl in einem Land das mit
eiserner Faust regiert wird in der Tat
lange darüber geschickt hatte diaz-canel
an den stärksten Tagen der Proteste
welche die Straßenfest in Herbern
erfüllten in seinen Kommuniqué ist
ziemlich nervös Erich sogar zur direkten
Konfrontation zwischen Anhängern und
Gegnern der Regierung auf die
müssen über unsere Leichen gehen wenn
Sie die Revolution konfrontieren wollen
bereit und werden auf der Straße sein
und kämpfen okay und rufen alle
revolutionäre des Landes alle
Kommunisten auf auf die Straße zu gehen
wie verteidigen die Revolution unter
allen revolutionieren in der ersten
Reihe stehen die Kommunisten
[Musik]
Residenz zu schlagen sie wurde vor mehr
als 40 Jahren gegründet und kleine
schwarze schüchtern zu wirken die sind
so etwas wie die Prätorianergarde des
kulissenriss
Ihren
und unseren zu verteidigen aber lass uns
nicht ablenken vielleicht ist das Ende
wie lange wird durchhalten können
[Musik]
Einlenken bis vor einem Monat noch
überwindbar
Selbständigkeit
Privatunternehmen Durchbruch
[Musik]
US embargo betont dass die Insel
bestraft aber nie das von der
kubanischen Regierung selbst errichtete
embargo also die Einschränkungen des
Hundes mit der ganzen Außenwelt und wenn
1 auf jeden Fall klar ist dann dass der
beispiellose sozial Aufstand Juli 2021
ein verzweifelter Schrei war das war
nicht zum Schluss der Diktatur geführt
hat aber dazu diente den Wunsch nach
Demokratie Huber weltweit gehört zu
verschaffen und genau an diesem Punkt
müssen wir zur zukünftigen politischen
Agenda kommen
[Musik]
dann um es klar zu sagen wenn die
Kommunistische Partei Kuba weiterhin so
reagieren will keine andere Wahl haben
als echte Wirtschaftsreform
durchzuführen marktorientierte Reform
die sie den Shopping in hinein anderes
Namen was ist diese Zeit ist vor allem
das wenn sich das Regime weiterhin
weigert ändern
schnell und seine Kumpane bereit sein
Kuba zu modernisieren um an der Macht
bleiben zu können werden diese Prozesse
zu einem Kuba mit mehr sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen Freiheiten führen oder
wird die Regierung den Weg von immer
mehr Repression wählen reichen die
derzeitigen Lockerung aus und das
landwirtschaftlichen stabilisieren und
welche Position sollte die
internationale Staatengemeinschaft
einnehmen teilt eure Meinung bitte wie
immer mit uns sind auch alle anderen ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat falls ja geht uns mit einem like
alte sind eine Freundin und vergesst
nicht unseren Kanal zu abonnieren mach's
gut und bis bald
[Musik]